what scares you everything not being in
control not knowing uh anticipation like
waiting for something to go wrong
i'm an addict and alcoholic so i have my
ups and downs yeah
my head is a bit
bit wonky
and sometimes i think even if you don't
know quite what it is that you want to
achieve
that if you just keep cracking on
towards it anyway that you know if you
do what you love doing this is what my
dad said to me he said if you do what
you love doing and you do it well then
everything should sort of fall into
place and you know and the great thing
about the arts is that it's something
that will always keep me company even in
my in in my quiet time when i'm on my
own so if you're going to do anything in
your arts first and foremost you know
it's one of your closest friends it'll
keep your companion so i think that's
that's massively important uh for me
it's kept me you know when i've been
unemployed that's that's what i've sort
of come back to is that would i do this
is it a vocation or is it is it a job
and i think it's more of a vocation to
be fair
another thing that my dad said was um
your job tom is to observe and reflect
right
and anything that gets in the way of the
telescope has to go
including yourself
i think that's what he was getting at is
also about being more irritated towards
the workplace you know because as we
focus more in the workplace
there's not as much time to laugh about
um because obviously there's time and
money involved as well now especially if
you're coming up with something from
nothing which is presumably what we all
do in the creative department is that
i'm selling a handful of nothing and and
hoping to come through with some some
results
and i'll put myself right out there for
the risk of it and i will fail
and it's okay to fail in fact you learn
more from failing and humiliation in my
game than than any than any other that i
know um and actually that seems to be
quite similar across the board in most
professions from the people that i've
met so it's good to fail it's not
embarrassing and humiliation is your
friend
everest is obvious to climb because it's
there it's about
personal everest you know you can't see
it
you know and that journey to the top of
the mountain and back down again is full
with hazards and no one can see it but
you so
never give up on a dream the only thing
that's brought me to where i am today is
supposed to happen in it i'm really
grateful to be here mate i want to help
other people and i'm really grateful
things have happened in my life it could
have gone one way
i think as human beings by nature as a
species
we're all thought
we have to constantly ask ourselves the
uncomfortable questions
i mean is the world
better for
me having been in it
and if the last few years have taught me
anything it's uh
is that rather than change the world to
better suit our needs how
can we change ourselves to better suit
the world that we all live in
thoughtfully examine
the roles we play and how to be well how
to best be abuse and to be of service
in a noble pursuit to make the world a
better place
i believe that perfection is
unattainable
but that doesn't stop us trying
and we should constantly be
evolving redefining
refining predicting analyzing
adapting
to whatever the world
throws at us you know and and in harmony
with that world
and if one is passionate and committed
in the noble pursuit of excellence
within their chosen field
be that
the arts technology
science humanitarianism conservationism
then i would say
one has a moral obligation
and uh an ethical duty
uh
to be of service
and to always strive to be part of the
solution and not the problem
after all it's a world that our children
would inherit
that's worth being a part of
that speaks to me
[Music]
passion
action
noble intention
creates progress
passion creates
progress
you